you
his lost poems I think frustrated by the
fact that I cannot lose scraps of poems
still in the making before they are
finished and so on I decided to take my
revenge and just write compensate myself
by writing a poem to my lost poems I
think sometimes of poems I have lost
maybe they're lost it was that saved the
world still they do get lost and I
recall them only when a fragment
levitates behind discarded invoices the
black-rimmed notice of a last goodbye a
birth a wedding invitation and other
milestones were lesser kind the moment
torments why beyond an instance passion
dubious flash Satori in a bar taxi or
restaurant an airport waiting lounge
that births this scribble on a stained
napkin or cast of the ephemeral once
resonates then spurns the mind the
morning after all that survives mimics a
wrinkled petal pressed between pages of
long discarded books a falling leaf
trapped briefly by the passing some it
flashes a mere shadow of memory but
filled with wistful accusations of
abandonment to late
no life to it the book is closed the
moments exaltation or despair drowned in
wine rivers shriveled in sons of Greater
Wars I turned these scrapbooks of a
moment's truth to cinders there
curling's curse in smoke one small
fugitive beyond recall of usurpers
summons by the morning after I think of
voices I have lost and touches the
fleeting brush of eyes that borrows deep
within the heart of need the pledge
unspoken the more than acts of faith
that forge an instant world in silent
pact with
strangers deeper deeper bonds and the
dearest loves embrace
you